(super high speed speaking)
(jazzy music)
- I think it's going to be interesting
because I talk a lot.
I can't shut up.
- I've always been very
intrigued by the idea of silence
as someone that does a lot of of talking.
- I think people are
going to be uncomfortable.
I think that's going to
make me uncomfortable,
and then I'm not going
to know how to respond.
- Even when I have strep throat
I still find ways to talk.
(whip)
(three bells chime)
(old fashioned jazz)
- [Voiceover] Do we need any new towels?
How many do we have right now?
- I could not communicate
something easily whatsoever.
Not even to save my life.
- [Voiceover] You hungry?
Alright.
Tacos?
You like Thai food?
- I could tell by the fourth,
when he finally got it right,
he's very exacerbated with me.
- [Voiceover] Eggs?
Over medium?
Veggie bacon?
Turkey bacon?
- As the meal went on, the
waiter stopped talking.
- [Voiceover] You're going
to share the fiesta nachos?
Would you like any meat in it?
Chicken?
- [Voiceover] No, I don't
think that was like too harsh.
Is that what you mean?
I don't think it was overbearing.
- I feel like very
gesture now is cataloged.
Like I have a dictionary of gestures.
Walk across the street to
get something to drink?
(whip)
(funky rock music)
- It was a lot harder than I
thought to not speak at all.
I think I think a lot more now
about how I use words and when.
- I am so relieved.
I felt there were so many
things that I left unsaid
because I had no way of communicating it.
- I think this did show me what it's like
to really listen to people more.
- I think I'm definitely more attuned now
to other people's nonverbal cues.
- The biggest think that I learned
is how lonely you can feel
surrounded by so many people
but you still feel like
you're in this place
where nobody can reach you.
- I think what this
taught me about listening
was how to really hone in
on what the person I was
speaking to really means.
- I think overall I've learned
that the ability to speak
when you want and how you want
is truly powerful and it's not something
I would be giving up any time soon.
(funky music)
(squeaky door)